14 years since the padres have been in
the playoffs hopefully tonight is the
night there's a lot at stake going on
there should be a lot of excitement at
the ballpark hopefully a lot of runs and
the potteries make it easy and the reds
that service gets the hand the ball to
justice sheffield he has been very good
as of late i can't wait to see what he
does against a very good padres team
payoff pitch to tatis junior
get him looking good pitch by sheffield
here's manny machado out of the two hole
he's hitting nine straight and that is
stung into center field for a base hit
and he continues to crush seattle here
in 2020. two aboard the return of eric
hosmer and they've got manny in a pickle
and tagged out by j.p crawford now that
is a big base running error mike
clevenger originally started to be on
the mound for this game here tonight has
been scratched and luis patino will take
them out making his first ever start in
the big leagues so two on it two out for
the mariners here at the bottom of the
first inning as luis coutinho gets the
start and now faces his former teammate
ty france
there we go base hit
dylan moore good speed bubbled out there
by myers what an at bedford ty france an
rbi single into right field the mariners
have a one to nothing lead here in the
bottom of the first inning and with two
outs padres making a little bit of noise
frank grisham will stand in for the
first time tonight against sheffield
tran has reached in 14 consecutive games
here's the 2-2 on the way swing and a
miss and a slider down on the way in the
dirt and again sheffield gets himself
out of trouble pitching change in the
bottom of the second innings have the
bases loaded with two down here in the
bottom half of the second here is kyle
lewis with the table set one two sit
down take three calls the game in
cincinnati has gone final and the white
sox defeat the reds five to nothing that
moves the padre magic number from two
to one tell me that's not gonna fire him
up a little bit what a great opportunity
with fernando tati's junior leading off
swinging at the first pitch and setting
it out to deep left center lewis on the
run will not get there it's up and off
the wall and fernando's off to the races
he's got two and he will hold with a
leadoff double here in the third
[Music]
a hug for his buddy and a lead off two
bagger
here's machado basic here probably ties
the game three homers in his last two
and that will get through the right side
for a base hit tatis on his way home
this game is tied one to one in the
third mandy don't touch him man he's in
frago he's on fire don't rub against him
here's jose marmaleos who struck out his
first time sieger at second the go-ahead
run the one-two to
swing and a miss it gets through the
wickets of nola all the way to the
backstop and now the maritals have
runners on the corners with only one
away an opportunity for terence to drive
it around he had a base hit his first
time up 2-1 oh that's hit well left
field that'll get a lot of guys running
seeger walks home
mar malayas he's on the giddy up he's
coming around
and a throw and they've got
terrence caught on a rundown they'll tag
him out but he gets the job done
knocking in two and americans have a 3-1
lead
tati's hard hit crawford can't get there
into left field fernando's got a pair of
hits and the padres have two men on for
manny machado the 3-2 pitch
swing and a miss by profile to pitch up
and away for strike three and that is
strikeout number four for justice
sheffield pitch the machado swing and a
ground ball right side taken by evan
white he's got it over the second for
one crawford's relay back to the pitch
of sheffield not in time
so first and third with two outs and
here is austin nola
and he's going to get it oh no bobbled
by france hangs in makes the play inning
over center fielder kyle lewis leading
off the bottom of the fifth inning
there's a high fly ball deep left field
that's gonna giddy up and get out of
here home run for kyle lewis
4-1 seattle kyle lewis with his 11th
home run of the season 28th run bad at
it upper deck straight away left field
kyle lewis number 11. now it's up to the
ball playing to try and close this one
down so here is kendall graven looking
to get back up on that horse after he
had a rough time a couple of days ago
two at night for tatis
hit hard zigger right there bobble stays
with it throws him out one down big out
here is third baseman manny machado fly
ball into shallow center field racing in
diving and making the catch kyle lewis
holy smokes what a catch by the kid off
the bat of manny with shadow lewis
racing in
dove for it made the catch this kid has
done it all kyle lewis
and with nobody out at the top of the
night the padres will bring the tying
run to the plates so two on and nobody
out for tommy pham
reached four and over crawford into left
field meyer's gonna have to hustle the
third he'll get there and guess what
slam diego the padres have the bases
loaded with nobody out padres have hit
seven grand slams this year jake had
number six and the 2-2 swinging the
ground ball back to toronto the throw to
the plate for one terenza's relay to
white at first and it's a one two three
double play
still the tying run now is at the plate
and now profiling the padres down to
their final strike
on the ground diegort right there dee
strange gordon throws him out america's
winning this ball game 4-1 even this
series well done by hirano to get out of
a big time jam